peu
[Musique]
il fallait s'y attendre matériaux roi de
l'emballage et du conditionnement la
matière plastique sous la haute
direction du nac dit 'tiens paco rabanne
a enlevé cette saison de nouveau bastion
[Musique]
jamais sans doute le polystyrène et le
chlorure de vinyle ne s'était trouvé en
aussi agréable compagnie l'heure est au
rafraîchissement général les classiques
eux-mêmes lancent leurs offensives
ainsi les maillots de chair et modulaire
dont le principe stratégique numéro 1 de
séduction et l'ouverture au centre
[Musique]
mais le procédé par infiltration a aussi
ses partisans
[Musique]
on
pour sa part michel tellin a consacré
tout son talent à mettre les maillots
sous cellophane recouvrir sans
dissimuler protégés sans occulter toutes
les règles d'or du conditionnement ont
été transposées avec audace et fantaisie
les thèmes sont inépuisables du modèle
pour petites filles modèles habitant
chez ses parents au suroît pour voyage
de noces
[Musique]
mais pour éblouir les beatniks il en
faut davantage que ce manque mais un
miroir des miroirs pour lesquelles on se
ferait volontiers alouettes
[Musique]